[Music]
Pat Sajak is saying goodbye to his home
of five decades Wheel of Fortune we're
getting near the end I mean it's been a
long time we're not going to do this for
another 40 years last August Pat hinted
to us about retiring and yesterday he
dropped the news saying well the time
has come I've decided that our 44th
season which begins in September will be
my last by this time you would have said
that's probably enough but this show
will not will not die it appears and I
may go before the show I don't think
Pat's retirement probably came as a big
shock to the higher ups I don't think he
really wanted to leave them sort of
hanging in the Lurch this is a very
planned business decision
[Music]
over the past 12 plus months Pat's had
some headline making interactions with
contestants that may have been the most
pointless Story Ever Told great and you
told it Scott please solve the darn
puzzle that's a horrible moment when you
know that everyone in America knows what
this is why don't I but you got it my
name is Pat Sajak s-a-j-a-k we've been
by Sajak side ever since he took over in
the early 80s for the ogmc Chuck Woolery
how long can it last I got about a week
and a half left and I'm taking off for
Rio
um I I don't know this may be the show
literally that's never canceled
so now the question who could replace
the longest running game show host ever
fans are already taking a spin at ideas
how many more years do you want to do
this wow
I think the odds are pretty well for
Vanna White to do it I mean obviously
she's done it in the past it stays with
the brand please welcome Pat's daughter
Maggie Sajak if his daughter really
wants this gig Pat is definitely you
know pushing for it but Ryan Seacrest
who left live in April is a rumored
front-runner after reportedly talking to
the producers he's back in L.A the show
shoots in La he knows these kind of
formats are really well you know what I
think that's a pretty good bet too I
want that job now we figured it out
I think there's been lots of
lots of Whoopi Goldberg is definitely a
wild card in here but does she really
want to do it we'll see I think if
they're smart they're going to make this
sort of you know tune in television with
different guest hosts it just builds the
buzz the buzz until the final
announcement when they say this is who
the new host is Pat will stay on behind
the scenes as quote a consultant for
three years following his last year
hosting people often wear out their
welcome in our business and we're happy
and proud that we have it